kourtney kardashian is unbothered by
scott disick's relationship with amelia
hamlin
i'm not putting my energy there a source
tells et that it's not weird for the
reality star to see her ex with another
woman
quote courtney has been in her own world
with travis
and they are so beyond obsessed with
each other i'm just like living life and
whatever happens happens but scott is
struggling with the fact his ex is
living life with her new boyfriend
travis barker
the source adds that he wishes court was
affected by his relationship
like he is about hers scott is a little
skeptical of courtney's new romance
and hurt by it if you remember the lord
said it's not easy seeing his ex move on
and keeping up with the kardashians i
just
don't like seeing you with another guy
or a guy it hurt me when you're with
somebody else
and like waking up to like looking at
pictures of you
and like with this guy you were dating
things have been heating up between
courtney and her blink 182 drummer
boyfriend since they first got together
back in january
i love it the couple has vacation
together and he even got her name
tattooed on his chest
as for scott he's been seeing amelia
since last november
earlier this week scott celebrated his
38th birthday
and his girlfriend gifted him a brand
new harley-davidson
motorcycle
the 19 year old model also shared this
sweet clip cozying up to her man
alongside the caption birthday cutie and
posted a tribute on insta writing
you light up my life and make my world
better i can't imagine what i would do
without you i'm so blessed to have met
you i love you
it's great earlier this month a source
told e.t that amelia is mature for her
age and
scott is her first serious boyfriend
they're planning on spending the summer
together in the hamptons